WHAT HAPPENED TO SKYPE:
In May of 2011, Microsoft
announced that they would be buying Skype for
$8.5 billion in cash. From the very beginning,
it seemed like Microsoft had overpaid for the
video conferencing platform. Just two years
before this, Skype had been sold for a third of
this price coming in at $2.75 billion. There was
no way Skype’s value had tripled within these
24 months, especially given the 2008 financial
recession. And Microsoft very much knew this,
but if they wanted to get Skype, this was the
price they had to pay because two other giants,
Google and Facebook, were also interested in
acquiring Skype. It appears that Microsoft had
won the bidding wars, but now, it was time for
the actual hard stuff. They needed to ensure
that this overpriced purchase would actually be
worth it over the long term. Unfortunately, by all
accounts, they would miserably fail at doing this.
Public distaste for Skype simply grew year after
year and people were simply waiting for a viable
alternative to pop up. For gamers, this turned out
to be Discord. For businesses and institutions,
this turned out to be Zoom. Things actually
got so bad that Microsoft themselves shutdown
Skype for business in the middle of 2021.
Hearing all this, you would think that Skype
was a massive failure, and technically
Skype itself was indeed a failure. But,
what if I told you that Skype as an investment
was actually a massive win for Microsoft. You see,
just as Skype started hitting its breaking point
in the late 2010s, Microsoft went out and iterated
on Skype themselves and created a new solution:
Microsoft Teams. If you’re a tech worker, you’re
probably extremely familiar with Microsoft Teams,
and this sound probably gives you nightmares. If
you’re not familiar with Teams, this is basically
the business equivalent of this sound. Anyway,
according to Microsoft themselves, Teams is
their fastest growing business app of all
time. And let’s not forget, Microsoft was
also the creators of Office and Outlook,
so this is truly an achievement. Between March and
June of 2020, Teams actually grew faster than Zoom
growing a whopping 894%. And today, Teams has
a total of 270 million users, which is not that
far behind Zoom’s 300 million active users. Not
to mention, Teams users are way more profitable
given that they're more likely to be business
users. In 2020 for example, Zoom pulled in just
over $4 billion while Teams actually pulled in
nearly $7 billion. Yet, all the media ever talks
about is Zoom. So, heres’ the rise and fall
of Skype and its insane resurrection as Teams.
THE RISE OF SKYPE:
Taking a look back, the story of Skype dates
back to 2003 to two Scandinavian men named
Niklas Zennstrom and Janus Friis. The idea behind
Skype wasn't to crack into the business world or
dominate video conferencing. The idea was actually
much simpler. The idea was to substantially reduce
the cost of long distance phone calls. If you have
family in other countries, you’re probably well
aware of just how expensive this is, and this
is still the case to this day. But, nowadays,
you’re first instinct wouldn’t be to hope on
Skype. It would probably be to use Facetime or
WhatsApp. Back in the early 2000s though, these
options didn’t even exist. So, you either had
to pay AT&T an arm and a leg or you had to put up
with MSN messenger. Skype’s founders were acutely
aware of this situation and they felt that the
industry was just asking for disruption. So,
like any good entrepreneurs, they got to work.
They would partner with some Estonian developers
and they would create a minimal viable product by
the end of the year. And they would call it Skype
which stood for “Sky peer to peer”. Skype
was a massive hit almost instantaneously.
There was clearly a bunch of cooped up demand
that was just waiting for a better solution, and
Skype was exactly that. The founders built on this
success by expanding into traditional phone calls
as well with the launch of SkypeOut. SkypeOut
allowed users to directly call a landline or
mobile phone from their computers. This probably
doesn’t sound like a big deal today, but back in
2005, this was insane because not everyone even
had computers. This meant that you could leverage
Skype even if only one person had access to a
computer, and the best part was that it costed
a mere 2 cents per minute. For perspective, if
you don’t have an international plan, AT&T will
shamelessly charge you $2.71 per minute and that’s
in 2022. Who knows how much AT&T charged in 2005.
Anyway, the cost and convenience of Skype made it
a no brainer. Within 18 months of launching, Skype
would cross 23 million registered users and within
2 years, they would cross 100 million downloads.
Skype was still very much just a startup, but
bigger corporations were already interested in
acquiring the business. And we weren’t talking
about tens of millions or even hundreds of
millions, we were talking about billions, $2.6
billion from eBay to be exact. Skype had gone
from 0 to $2.6 billion in matter of 2.5 years. Not
a bad days work, but Skype was still just getting
started. At the end of 2005, Skype would launch
video calling and in mid 2006, they would launch
support for massive calls with up to 100 people.
By the end of 2007, Skype would reach 220 million
registered users and by all accounts, they were
crushing it. But, despite all this growth, eBay
was finding it more and more difficult to keep up
with Skype. There was virtually no synergy between
the two companies, so it was basically like
running two different businesses. Soon enough,
eBay just wanted out, so they would sell Skype
to the first buyer they could find for a terrible
valuation of $2.75 billion. These buyers would
simply turn around and flip Skype to Microsoft
a few years later for $8.6 billion in cold hard
cash, and that brings us into the Microsoft era.
THE DEATH OF SKYPE:
Microsoft bought the top. That’s simply the truth
and there’s no way around it. To make things
worse, not only did they buy the top, but they
overpaid at the top due to the bidding war. But,
wait a minute, hold up what happened? Wasn’t Skype
growing at an insane pace with no end in sight?
Well, unfortunately, the reality was that there
was an end in sight and reasoning was no obvious.
The number one selling factor of Skype was its
functionality. People didn’t use it because it had
a cool UI or great integration and synergy or any
of that. People used it simply because it solved a
problem. But, as we moved into the 2010s, there
were several services that could solve the same
problem, but these other services also came with
a bunch of extra bells and whistles. WhatsApp,
for example, actually offered an enjoyable
mobile experience unlike Skype. Meanwhile,
Google Hangouts and Apple Facetime were able to
tap into the massive networks of Gmail and iPhone
users. And for most people, switching to these
services was a no brainer. Why settle for just
functionality when you could opt for functionality
and a great user experience. This isn’t to say
that Skype stopped growing per se. In fact,
in terms of pure numbers, they continued their
exponential growth into the billions of users. The
problem though was that these weren’t happy users.
These were users that were becoming increasingly
frustrated, and the only reason they used Skype
was because everyone around them was using
it. It was the classic case of, it was popular
because it was already popular. Likely the
two biggest complaints about skype were that
the UI sucked and the service itself was not as
reliable as competitors. The first point is not
that surprising. I mean, we’re talking about
Microsoft here. Despite their enormous size,
they’ve never been able to get mobile right.
I mean just think about the Windows Phone
which lost them $8 billion. The problem was
that Microsoft was always trying to import
a computer basd experience onto mobile devices
which simply didn’t translate well. Meanwhile,
their competitors were reimagining how every
task could be done on a phone from scratch,
and the competitors destroyed Microsoft
everytime. As for the reliability problem,
this wasn’t exactly Microsoft’s fault, but they
weren’t able to fix it either. The reason that
Skype was so unreliable was because it was a
peer to peer service. The reliability of a peer
to peer connection was simply uncomparable to a
server based connection backed by a $13 billion
data center. Microsoft tried to address this by
moving Skype to the cloud, but this move was kind
of always botched. Not to mention, this move
also kind of backfired as it made people think
that Microsoft was trying to track their data. And
if you were gonna let Microsoft collect your data,
you might as well let Google and Facebook
collect your data. At least, you’ll have a good
UI there. And if you want some quantitative data
regarding just how much people hated Skype, well,
in June of 2017, the average app store rating
for Skype drop from 3.5 stars to 1.5 stars. Yeah,
it was that bad, but at the same time, no one
cared enough to switch either until the pandemic.
People figured that if they were gonna use video
conferencing on a regular basis, they had to
find a better solution and the answer was Zoom.
And this pretty much sealed the fate of Skype.
RESURRECTION AS TEAMS:
During all of this, Microsoft was by no
means oblivious to what was happening. They
were literally waiting to get destroyed in the
consumer market. But, at the same time, Microsoft
oddly didn’t mind. You see, the entire company
was moving away from consumer products. I mean,
they’ve literally made Windows and Office free for
consumers. The reason for this is that Microsoft
is no longer a consumer business. The majority of
their revenue actually comes from b2b revenue for
things like cloud infrastructure and licensing.
With that being said, Skype no longer fit inside
their wheelhouse. Something that did fit though
was business video conferencing. Microsoft already
had strong relationships with virtually every
company in the world given that basically every
company has to licenses Windows, Office, and
Outlook. So, why not sell them another solution
that seamlessly integrated with these products.
And this led to the launch of Skype for Business
in 2015. Microsoft quickly realized though that
the Skype branding wasn’t doing them any favors,
so they would embark on a complete rebranding
which led to the launch of Microsoft Teams in
2017. It wasn’t all sunshines and rainbows though
as most businesses already had established video
conferencing systems from Cisco. Cisco Webex was
nothing to brag about, but it got the job done
and companies didn’t see a reason to switch. As
a result, adoption of Teams was lackluster to say
the least. By the end of 2017, Teams only had
2 million users, and even by the end of 2018,
Teams only had 8 million users. 2019 was a much
better year for Teams as they finally got into the
tens of millions of users, but the breakthrough
obviously didn’t come till 2020. As we all know,
2020 forced everyone to reevaluate their video
conferencing solutions, and the choice was pretty
clear. WebEx was an obvious no. If you’re not
familiar with WebEx, it’s basically the business
equivalent of Skype. This left companies with
two options: Zoom or Teams. Both products offered
leading conferencing solutions, but Teams had a
slight leg up on Zoom which was integration with
Microsoft’s other products. For companies
that already relied on Microsoft products,
this synergy was simply too good to pass on,
and I think you can guess what happened next.
THE DOMINATION OF TEAMS:
Today, Teams doesn’t receive all that much
attention just like Microsoft themselves. But,
don’t let this fool you, Teams is the real
king of video conferencing. For most people,
using Zoom was an unfortunate temporary reality,
and they ditched Zoom as soon as they could. This
is very much reflected in Zoom’s stock graph.
For most companies, however, using Teams is a
permanent solution. And given that companies are
pretty hesitant on switching services, they’re
probably locked in for several years if not
decades. So, Microsoft’s $8.5 billion acquisition
has turned into $6.8 billion in revenue every
single year. And that was as of 2020 when Teams
had 75 million users. Since then, their user count
has grown nearly 4 fold to 270 million. So Teams
revenue today is definitely above $10 billion and
probably closer $20 billion. And if you’re still
not convinced about Team’s success, just listen
to this. Last quarter, Microsoft made $5.3 billion
from Windows, their most well known product. If
we annualize this, we get about $21.2 billion per
year. In other words, Team’s revenue is literally
comparable to that of Windows, and it’s probably
just a matter of time until Teams overtakes
Windows altogether. Also, the sector that Teams
is part of is already at $11.5 billion per quarter
which is twice of Windows, so who knows, maybe
Teams has already overtaken Windows. And that’s
why Skype was likely Microsoft’s best acquisition
of all time. Skype itself didn’t work out all
that well, but it gave rise to the behemoth that
is Teams. Did you hate Skype? Comment that down
below. Also, drop a like if you would like to
see more case studies. And of course, consider
checking out our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider subscribing
to see more questions logically answered.